>>> A ONCE IN A GENERATION
WINTER STORM IS KEEPING
AMERICANS INDOORS, AND A LOCAL
SPORTS REPORTER IN IOWA IS
KEEPING IT REAL AFTER BEING
FORCED TO GO OUTDOORS.
>> MARK, HOW YOU FEELING UP
THERE?
>> AGAIN, THE SAME WAY I FELT
ABOUT EIGHT MINUTES AGO WHEN YOU
ASKED ME THAT SAME QUESTION.
I NORMALLY DO SPORTS.
EVERYTHING IS CANCELED HERE FOR
THE NEXT COUPLE OF DAYS.
SO WHAT BETTER TIME TO ASKS THE
SPORTS GUY TO COME IN ABOUT FIVE
HOURS EARLIER THAN HE WOULD
NORMALLY WAKE UP, GO STAND OUT
IN THE WIND AND THE SNOW AND THE
COLD, AND TELL OTHER PEOPLE NOT
TO DO THE SAME.
I DIDN'T EVEN REALIZE THAT THERE
WAS A 3:30 ALSO IN THE MORNING
UNTIL TODAY.
CAN I GO BACK TO MY REGULAR JOB?
I'M PRETTY SURE, RYAN, THAT YOU
GUYS ADDED AN EXTRA HOUR TO THE
SHOW JUST BECAUSE SOMEBODY LIKES
TORTURING ME.
>> THAT CLIP OF CNN AFFILIATE
KWWL REPORTER MARK WOODLEY IS
GOING VIRAL, AND MARK IS WITH US
NOW FOR MY FAVORITE SEGMENT OF
THE DAY.
MARK, I SPENT ALMOST A DECADE IN
LOCAL NEWS DOING EXACTLY WHAT
YOU WERE JUST FORCED TO DO, AND
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY TIMES
I WANTED TO SAY WHAT YOU DID,
BUT DIDN'T HAVE THE GUTS TO.
SO I HAVE TO KNOW, WERE YOU
PLANNING TO SAY THIS AHEAD OF
TIME, OR DID IT ALL JUST COME
OUT LIVE?
>> I THINK THAT'S JUST A BIT OF
WHO I AM.
YOU KNOW, ON AIR, I LOVE TO GIVE
MY COWORKERS GRIEF.
I THINK THE FACT THAT I DIDN'T
FIND OUT UNTIL THE DAY BEFORE
THAT I WAS WORKING THE MORNING
SHOW -- I KNEW I WAS GOING TO DO
WEATHER ON THURSDAY, BUT A GUY
CALLED IN THE AFTERNOON AND I
FOUND OUT IT WAS THE MORNING
SHOW AND I NORMALLY DO THE 10:00
SHOW, GET OFF WORK ABOUT 11:00
AND GO TO BED.
I DIDN'T WORK ON WEDNESDAY, BUT
I DIDN'T HAVE THAT TIME TO
ADJUST MY SLEEP SCHEDULE.
I DON'T THINK I FELL ASLEEP
UNTIL ABOUT 11:00 AND I WAS
RUNNING ON ABOUT THREE HOURS OF
SLEEP AT THAT TIME, AND SOME
THINGS MAYBE I WOULDN'T HAVE
SAID IF I HAD SLEPT FOR EIGHT
HOURS, BUT, YOU KNOW, IT IS WHAT
IT IS.
WE COVER THESE THINGS EVERY
SINGLE YEAR.
IT'S ALL THE SAME, AND I THINK
SOMETIMES VIEWERS MIGHT TUNE IT
OUT, AND I THOUGHT MAYBE IF I
BRING ATTITUDE TO IT, PEOPLE
MIGHT PAY ATTENTION.
IT'S A SERIOUS STORM.
I TOOK IT VERY SERIOUSLY.
YOU'RE SEEING 90 SECONDS OUT OF
15 TO 20 MINUTES OVER MY TIME.
THE REST WAS SERIOUS, MAKING
SURE PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, KNOW THAT
THEY NEED TO DO TO BE SAFE, BUT
IT'S JUST KIND OF WHO I AM, AND
THANKFULLY BOSSES ARE AT LEAST
RIGHT NOW, THEY'RE ON BOARD WITH
IT.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, YOU HAD FUN WITH IT.
YOU'VE GONE VIRAL.
YOU NOW HAVE TONS OF FANS.
I HAVE TO KNOW HOW DID YOUR
MANAGERS AND FIELD DIRECTORS
FEEL ABOUT IT?
DID YOU GET IN TROUBLE?
>> YOU KNOW, I HAD SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE LIKE I SAID,
THE ACTUAL SEGMENTS, THEY DIDN'T
COME OFF LIKE THAT, BUT WHEN YOU
SPLICE IT ALL TOGETHER, YOU
KNOW, IT'S LIKE A MOVIE TRAILER
FOR A BAD COMEDY FILM.
ALL THE FUNNY PARTS ARE IN THE
TRAILER.
THE FUNNY PARTS WERE THE STUFF
THAT YOU DIDN'T SEE.
NOBODY THOUGHT ABOUT IT WHEN WE
WERE DONE WITH THE MORNING SHOW,
AND THEN I CUT THAT STUFF UP
TOGETHER AND I WASN'T PLANNING
ON PUTTING IT ON TWITTER.
IT WAS MY SISTER-IN-LAW WHO
SAID, YOU'VE GOT TO TWEET THIS.
I JUST PUT IT ON FACEBOOK FOR MY
FRIENDS AND FAMILY TO KIND OF
LAUGH AT.
I PUT IT ON TWITTER, THINKING,
20, 30 PEOPLE ARE GOING TO SEE
THIS, AND THE MANAGERS AREN'T
GOING TO CARE BECAUSE IT'S NOT
GOING TO GO ANYWHERE, AND WITHIN
HOURS I'M GETTING THESE TEXT
MESSAGES, LIKE, DUDE, YOU'RE
GOING VIRAL.
JUDD APATOW RETWEETED YOU.
DAVID CROSS -- DAVID CROSS IS
ONE OF MY FAVORITES.
IT WAS INSANE.
RICH EISEN AND AT THIS POINT,
90% OF ME IS KIND OF GIDDY ABOUT
IT.
THE OTHER 10% IS, LIKE, AM I
GOING TO GET IN TROUBLE FOR
THIS?
BECAUSE SORT OF IN MY OWN WAY, I
CALL OUT THE STATION.
FOR ME, IT WAS IN GOOD FUN.
WAS THERE SOME TRUTH TO IT?
OH, ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK EVERY REPORTER WHO HAS
DONE THIS HAS WANTED TO SAY
THAT, AND I WAS TIRED ENOUGH TO
LET IT COME OUT.
>> I'M ONE OF THEM.
ANY CHANCE YOU'LL SWITCH FROM
SPORTS TO WEATHER?
>> THERE HAVE BEEN SO MANY
COMMENTS LIKE HE'S GOING TO BE
THE NEW WEATHER GUY.
BLIZZARD COVERAGE FROM NOW ON.
THAT IS MY ABSOLUTE NIGHTMARE.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, WE'RE A BIT
SHORTHANDED LIKE EVERY NEWSROOM
IN THE COUNTRY, AND THAT'S WHY I
WAS IN THE SITUATION IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
MY GM CAME OUT AND SHOT SOME OF
THOSE LATER LIVE SHOTS ON THAT
MORNING SHOW, BUT -- SO I'M A
TEAM PLAYER.
IF I'M ASKED, SURE, I'LL DO IT,
BUT THAT WOULD BE MY ABSOLUTE
NIGHTMARE.
SO I HOPE TO GOD THEY DO NOT ASK
ME TO EVER DO THAT AGAIN.
>> WELL, MARK WOODLEY, A SPORTS
REPORTER WHO IS NOT GOING TO
TURN INTO A WEATHER REPORTER NO
MATTER -- OR A METEOROLOGIST NO
MATTER HOW MUCH ANYONE OF US
WOULD LIKE IT.
YOU'RE NOW A PERSONAL LEGEND AND
HERO TO MYSELF, BUT TO PROBABLY
ALL THE LOCAL NEWS REPORTERS
CURRENT AND FORMER ALL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY FOR SAYING WHAT
WE'VE ALL THOUGHT SO MANY TIMES.
THANKS SO MUCH, AND CAN I JUST
SAY I WISH YOU HAD BEEN OUTSIDE
FOR THIS.
YOU.
LOOK WAY TOO COMFORTABLE IN
THERE.
>> I FEEL WAY TOO COMFORTABLE.
ACTUALLY, I FEEL REALLY GOOD
RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T THINK -- IT'S
ACTUALLY -- I BELIEVE WORSE
TODAY THAN IT WAS YESTERDAY OUT
THERE.
THE WIND I